bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
aujourd'hui c'est un anniversaire
important c'est la 100e émission
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler des manipulations marché bon
anniversaire hespel bonjour olivier je
souhaite aussi un très bel anniversaire
ravis de partager cette émission à vos
côtés alors pour l'occasion dans cette
émission on va revenir sur les
différentes affaires qui ont secoué la
bourse ces dernières semaines il y a eu
bien sûr la sphère gamestop mais aussi
des tweets d'un certain elon musk alors
à quel moment peut-on parler de
manipulation boursière où sont les
limites de ce qui est légal et de ce qui
ne l'est pas enfin quelles conséquences
ces agissements peuvent avoir sur
l'économie réelle ce sont là les
questions qui vont nous occuper dans
cette émission et pour cela en deuxième
partie nous serons en liaison avec
philippe béchade ancien trader et
rédacteur en chef de la bourse au
quotidien la faire à gamestop aux
libyens vous vous en souvenez elle avait
secoué wall street il ya quelques
semaines une coordination de traders
amateurs en ligne avait permis de faire
grimper l'action est d'aller à
l'encontre des paris à la baisse des
aides stern depuis
alors bien sûr plusieurs enquêtes sont
en cours elles doivent déterminer s'il
ya eu ou non manipulation des marchés
alors olivier concrètement la
manipulation de cours en quoi est-ce que
cela consiste en la manipulation
aujourd'hui on c'est une manipulation on
va dire de zéro c'est à dire que avant
on le faisait ça fait 30 ans que les
cours sont manipulés ça a été une grande
période les cours sur les small caps
puisque c'était beaucoup plus facile à
manipuler oui qu'il y avait de moins de
volume donc la manipulation était facile
aujourd'hui oui je sais ce que pour
expliquer ce que c'est que les small
caps les small caps et des petites
valeurs sur lequel il y avait très peu
de volume en fait très peu de
capitalisation échangés par jour
et donc il était assez facile de les
manipuler alors on les manipule et à
l'ancienne c'est-à-dire ont profité d'un
article dans un journal ou d'un
communiqué d'analystes avec star est
donc maintenant on le fait sur les
réseaux c'est beaucoup plus facile et ça
permet de toucher un nombre important de
de traders vous avez le aussi la
possibilité de cette manipulation qui
est encore plus facile parce que vous
avez de nouveaux traders vous savez que
il ya eu des milliers de comptes qui ont
été ouverts aux états unis chez un
broker qui s'appelle robin hood et
pourquoi parce que vous avez des gens
qui ont été attirés par dirait de
l'argent assez facile et qui ont mis
même mis une partie de leurs chèques
vous savez que crump avait fait avait
envoyé un chèque à tous les américains
et que 70% de ce chèque s'est retrouvé
sur des comptes ouverts en bourse
chez robin hood alors le problème si
vous voulez c'est que j'aurai même chose
qui en profitent réellement de ces
manipulations de cours
malheureusement ce n'est pas ce qu'on
pense c'est à dire c'est pas les petites
sardines comme les avait appelés à 10 la
jeunesse les petites sardines qui en ont
au final profiter c'est des requins qui
ont bien l'habitude de gens de
manipulation et qui en ont profité et
qui ont fait rentrer les petits parce
que il ya toujours c'est toujours la
même chose vous tant que le cours monte
virtuellement vous êtes riche
virtuellement vous allez gagner de
l'argent mais pour réellement le gagner
il faut sortir du titre il faut le
revendre à un moment pour concrétiser
ces plus values et là c'est bien
pratique d'avoir des milliers de petits
contes qui vous achète ce que vous avez
acheté vous bien plus bas et que vous
leur revendre et donc voilà en quoi
consistent les manipulations alors
aujourd'hui il ya aussi beaucoup de
manipulations notamment de la part de
notre ami
musk qui eux
qui a qui manipulent aujourd'hui encore
plus facilement le bitcoin et les crypto
monnaie en général pourquoi mais tout
simplement parce que le bitcoin n'ayant
pas je dirais de d'existence légale
n'étant pas régulé et bien vous pouvez
aujourd'hui ouvertement manipulé le
cours sans avoir de problèmes avec les
autorités de tutelle
donc c'est bien pratique alors on va
revenir sur tous ces détails dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission et
cette semaine pour parler manipulation
boursière nous sommes en liaison avec
philippe béchade bonjour monsieur vous
êtes ancien trader et rédacteur en chef
de la bourse au quotidien merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ogier alors philippe béja dans la
manipulation boursière dans les faits
c'est un délit puni par la loi qui est
assimilable quelque sorte à de
l'escroquerie
il existe plusieurs autorités qui ont
pour mission de veiller à ce qu'aucune
manipulation de cours n ait lieu pour
autant quand on regarde par exemple la
sphère gamestop on voit que malgré cet
arsenal législatif
il est possible aujourd'hui d'intenter
des actions pour influencer les cours
oui là ça va être complexe parce que
dans le cadre de gamestop vous avez
comme l'a bien dit olivier des milliers
même des centaines de milliers de
comptes de particuliers qui se sont
inscrits sur des forums
notamment en forum reddit et des forums
avec on va dire un objet qui est
effectivement de chasser en meute de
façon à provoquer des décalages de cours
absolument un terrier lactique et j'ose
dire et provoquer même ce qu'on appelle
des anomalies de gama c'est à dire que
vous avez des gens des teneurs de marché
qui vendent des options sur un titre de
façon à améliorer un petit peu leur
rentabilité et se couvrir et un moment
compte le décalage du cours à la hausse
devient trop violent bien vous êtes à
votre tour obligé de racheter les
options que vous avez vendu sur ses
titres en couverture sinon vous allez
vous retrouver avec des des écarts de
valeur sur l'option qui peuvent même
dépasser la valeur du titre on a assisté
à des distorsions d'une violence qu'on
n'a jamais qu'on n'avait jamais reconnu
et c'est cette stratégie constitue
consistant à chasser en meute
il faut évidemment un chef de meute mais
qui vraiment à influencer les dizaines
centaines de milliers de petits
opérateurs
c'est très difficile à savoir parce que
l'influent soeurs se cache derrière un
pseudo s'il a pris les précautions
suffisantes hills et anonymisée sur les
réseaux autrement dit on ne peut même
pas remonter à la source de
l'information et si tenté qu'il y ait
une information quand on vous dit
allez-y les gars on va défoncer les
hedge-fund moi je sais que ils ont x
dizaines de milliers
deux positions notionnels sur les
options et quand on va faire exploser
l'option à la hausse on va faire est
également explosé les hedge-fund qui
vont être obligés de se racheter à tout
prix d'où le fait que gamestop par
exemple a pu voir son cours
passé en quelques mois de 5 $ et je
crois même qu'on était même à un moment
en dessous de 4 $ à 500 $
avec ce qu'on appelle effectivement des
explosions de deux des explosions de
gama autrement dit des teneurs de marché
qui explose en plein vol parce qu'ils
sont obligés de racheter leurs positions
à tout prix donc voilà j'ai est restée
presque le crime parfait parce que
difficile de mettre un nom sur la
personne ou les personnes qui ont
déclenché le mouvement alors il a bien
un ou deux qui ont été appelés à
témoigner avec robin hood sur justement
c'est énorme décalage de volatilité mais
les vrais les vrais initiateur des
mouvements moi même j'ai une vague idée
de qui ça peut être mais je ne le sais
pas formellement
alors olivier on va laisser un peu de
côté le côté amateur de la chose pour se
concentrer sur ce qui se fait par des
professionnels il y a le shorting la
vente d'actions à découvert mais aussi
le spoofing pardon hein pour ces termes
un peu barbare qui consiste à offrir des
titres à la vente ou l'achat dans
l'attention des nuls et l'ordre juste
avant qu'il soit exécuté
olivier ces techniques elles sont
utilisées par les traders professionnels
et ce qu'elles sont encadrés et est ce
qu elles sont assimilables à de la
manipulation de cours oui et alors enfin
c'est là aussi ce sont des techniques
qu'on avait depuis depuis que la bourse
existe va surtout qu'elle est passée à
l'électronique et donc il n'y a rien de
nouveau sous le soleil si vous voulez
simplement ce qui arrive aujourd'hui
c'est que ça devient public mais
c'étaient des choses cette action-là
sont concrètement de la manipulation
mais c'est de la manipulation mais c'est
de la manipulation de cours si vous
voulez le le le ce que je vous dise et
c'est des professionnels qui au final
gagne de l'argent dans ces histoires
c'est pas c'est pas le petit particulier
le petit particulier est là pour se
faire tondre en bourse
il n'est pas là pour autre chose il faut
être faut être clair on a cette espèce
de mythe de l'argent facile qui a attiré
des milliers de personnes
mais le problème c'est que ils sont pas
là pour gagner de l'argent ils sont là
ils sont utilisés par des gros pour que
eux les gros gagnent de l'argent et mais
c'est en effet tout c'est toutes ces
manipulations de cours que vous pouvez
faire en mettant un ordre en le retirant
etc
tout ça c'est de la manipulation de
cours c'est une autre manipulation de
cours' est une autre façon de faire mais
c'est une façon qui existent et qui
existent tous les jours
alors après il ya des contrôles qui ont
été qui ont été exercées et si vous
voulez c'est c'est très facile pour un
banquier dia ba oui mais je suis désolé
en fait je me suis trompé en entrant
l'ordre externe
on sait tous le faire c'est pas très
compliqué le aucune autorité de tutelle
ne va s'amuser à dépouiller toutes les
transactions parce que il y en a des
milliers qui sont qui sont faites et
donc ne vous inquiétez pas pour eux ils
ne finiront pas en prison philippe
béchade olive et le des sorties bowling
ce sont des manipulations boursières
mais pourtant c'est légal parfois légal
ce n'est pas légal et ce n'est pas
illégal on est typiquement dans la zone
grise
quand olivier parle du spoofing ça
consiste à abuser non pas des opérateurs
chair et de sang derrière leurs claviers
ça consiste à abuser des systèmes de
trading automatique qui font eux mêmes
du hedging qui protège des positions qui
arbitrent parfois avec des options ce
dont je vous parlais à propos de
gamestop ou d'un seul coup à certaines
options ans ont valu en sont venus à
valoir plus que le titre lui même et
l'autre manipulation que je qualifierais
elle part par contre de véritables délit
d'initié permanent bien par exemple
robin wood vous passer des ordres
gratuitement comme vous le savez quand
c'est gratuit c'est que c'est vous le
produit donc qu'est ce que fait l'eau
bénite pour gagner de l'argent avec des
opérateurs à qui on ne facture pas
justement les commissions de transaction
eh bien ils vendent leur formation c'est
à dire qu'est ce que vont faire les
centaines de milliers de détenteurs de
comptes quand il rentre un ordre
la machine vérifie que cet ordre est
conforme et c est bien là le seul fait
de saisir un ordre donne une information
sur ce que va faire ou ce que vont faire
des centaines de milliers d'opérateurs
qui sur un forum quel qu'il soit d'un
seul coup viennent d'avoir un feu vert
pour lancer une attaque sur tel ou tel
titre donc l'information elle est vendue
à de très très gros opérateur qui savent
exactement si d'un seul coup la masse
d'or droite à l'achat ou va être à la
vente et donc ils vont acheter avant ça
s'appelle faire du french writing
c'est à dire se positionner avant que
des centaines de milliers de personnes
et appuyez sur la touche valide
eux ils savent exactement qu'est ce qui
va être rentré dans la machine avant que
ça soit validé et il se place devant
alors pour les robin hood
finalement ça s'est relativement
indolore parce que qu'ils achètent un
gamestop à 120 dollars 80 ou à 120,95
étant donné qu'on leur dit qu'ils vont
doubler la mise dans les trois jours
ils se fichent bien d'avoir fait cadeau
de 10 15 20 cents à quelqu'un qui aura
devancé leurs ordres et qui aura revendu
immédiatement
plusieurs centaines de milliers de fois
en encaissant plusieurs centaines de
milliers de fois ce petit écart de 10 20
30 cents que sais-je parce que dans une
seconde mais comme le disait olivier
c'est pas quelques milliers de
transactions qui ont lieu qu'il faudrait
dépouillés ce sont parfois des centaines
de milliers d'opérations qui sont
effectués à la vitesse de la lumière par
des machines et il ya des machines qui
sont là pour capter plusieurs centaines
de milliers de fois par minute plusieurs
millions de fois par jour de micro de
micro écart mais qui sont gagnant à tous
les coups
vous avez une entreprise qui s'appelle
vertu et qui se vantait il ya quelques
années de cela de n'avoir fait aucune
journée de pertes pendant je ne sais
plus combien 36 mois autrement dit ces
gens là gagne à tous les coups
en grattant un petit quelque chose
systématiquement millisecondes après
millisecondes
alors ce n'est pas de la manipulation de
cours mais c'est quelque chose qui est
évidemment choquant mais qui n'est je le
répète pas illégal puisque on se situe
en fait dans la zone grise et où
personne n'a vraiment jamais jugé utile
et nécessaire de légiférer et de réguler
sa merci philippe béchade on va marquer
une courte pause et on revient dans un
instant bienvenue dans ces caches si
vous nous rejoignez au sommaire cette
semaine la manipulation boursière et
pour cela nous sommes en liaison avec un
philippe béchade ancien trader et
rédacteur en chef de la bourse au
quotidien alors messieurs vous allez
voir que parfois un seul tweet suffi à
faire changer les cours de la bourse
c'est le cas par exemple avec les tweets
du patron de tesla elon musk
explications avec le tiroir cash
d'antoine basse
on en a déjà parlé dans ces caches les
marchés sont devenus un peu fous ces
dernières années aujourd'hui un seul
tweet et les bourses du monde entier
peuvent s'emballer
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a été reproché
plusieurs fois lots de masques
le patron de tesla ou de space x ayant
une influence tech house et oui tu peux
faire monter en flèche en titre en
bourse
on l'a vu récemment avec la faire
gamestop ou musk avait participé à
l'énorme coup réalisé par les
boursicoteurs musk avait d'ailleurs été
sanctionnée en 2018 après avoir annoncé
envisager de retirer sa société tesla de
la bourse américaine si le cours de
l'action n'atteignez pas 420 dollars
sanctionné par la sec l'autorité des
marchés américains à qui il entretient
depuis des relations tendues dirons nous
n'hésitant pas à se moquer ou à
provoquer quand il le peut l'asec
l'avait ainsi condamné à une grosse
amende et a dorénavant faire approuver
ces tweets sur tesla afin d'éviter de
faire monter la valeur du titre de
manière artificielle
en somme éviter une manipulation mais
depuis quelques semaines le milliardaire
s'est attaqué à une autre valeur en
pleine expansion le pde cogne faisant
des louanges du crypto actifs sur le
réseau de l'oiseau bleu investissant 1,5
milliard de dollars via tesla et
promettant que ces véhicules pourraient
bientôt être achetés en bitcoin il a
participé ainsi à faire monter sa valeur
jusqu'à 57 mille dollars
plusieurs accusations de manipulation du
marché crypto ou doc émerger
notamment de l'économiste renommée
nouriel roubini surnommé docteur doom
aux états unis la sec qui colle donc aux
basques des lone depuis deux ans serait
également en train de lancer une
nouvelle enquête
d'autant que début 2000 21 après
l'élection de joe biden l'autorité des
marchés américains s'est trouvé un
nouveau président gary gensler fin
connaisseur du bitcoin est peut être un
adversaire à la mesure des landes musk
alors olivier on vient de le voir un
elon musk qui est surveillée de très
près par la sec l'organisme américain de
réglementation et de contrôle des
marchés financiers olivier vous parliez
en première partie de manipulation à
l'ancienne est ce que tu avec ce genre
de personnage qui est le musk de par sa
personnalité sa façon de faire et ce
qu'il est en train de créer concrètement
de nouvelles règles non il est pas en
train de créer de nouvelles règles
il a il a manipulé son son cours donc le
cours de tesla la sec puis est tombé
dessus il s'en est tiré qu'au mont
sentir aux états unis c'est à dire qu'il
a fait un chèque de 27 millions de
dollars à la sec
ce qui a mis fin aux poursuites il a
quand même écopé de trois ans
d'interdiction de gérer donc il avait
mis un homme de paille devant lui sur
sur tesla
mais au départ l'intention de la sec
étaient de l'interdire de gérer avis et
et en échange de ce petit chèque il
il a réussi à passer outre maintenant
qu'est ce qu'il fait à effet tout
simplement il a il a bien compris la
vente âge d'aller manipuler des crypto
pourquoi parce que les crypto n'étant
pas réguler la sec ne peut pas s'en
mêler et donc ils risquent pas grand
chose alors peut-être que les les
autorités américaines va changer les
choses vis-à-vis de ça mais aujourd'hui
il a beau jeu de manipuler le bitcoin
puisqu'il sait qu'ils risquent rien en
revanche il sait aussi qui va gagner
beaucoup d'argent parce que les gens le
suivent aveuglément et en faisant
quelque chose qui l'a qui devrait
totalement interdit c'est à dire que je
sache
et cela n'est pas une banque ni un
broker de bitcoin est donc aujourd'hui
tesla devrait gagner de l'argent en
vendant des voitures mais
malheureusement il n'en gagne pas donc
pour faire monter son cours il n'a que
le choix de transgresser un peu les
règles
le problème si vous voulez c'est que
c'est que c'est toujours la même chose
pourquoi le fait-il tout simplement
parce que je vous rappelle que le
salaire de monsieur elon musk n'est pas
dépendant des résultats économiques de
sa société mais bien du cours de bourse
et donc chaque centaine de de 2,2
millions gagnés sur la capitalisation
boursière lui permet lui d'engrais
d'engranger quelques milliards de plus
fils aimé shader olivier l'a souligné il
est difficile de mettre fin à ce genre
de pratique alors quel genre de
régulation de ces plateformes
pourrait-on imaginer si l'on parle des
crypto acsi chaque je me refuse à créer
un qualifié de crypto monnaie
des économistes bien fusée imminent que
moi ont démontré que décrit plus actif
ne sont pas des menées et qu' ils
satisfont au maximum à un ou deux
critères sur quatre ou cinq pour qu un
crypto actifs devienne une monnaie donc
comment est-ce qu'on peut réguler ça je
dis tout simplement on ne peut pas pas
plus qu'on ne peut réguler je dirais
cette tendance naturelle de l'homme a
gagné beaucoup d'argent en ne faisant
rien c'est à dire par exemple avoir eu
le flair d'acheter un crypto hâtif au
moment où il valait quelques millièmes
je dis bien pas de mine et pas des pas
des dollars à des millièmes de dollars
jusqu'à ce que ça vaille par exemple un
dollars voire plus et c'est tellement
facile de se servir de la naïveté ou de
l'appât du gain vous faites 5 10 15 20
fois la mise
qui résisterait à ça donc le bitcoin
illustre quelque chose qui existe de
toute éternité gagner de l'argent en ne
faisant rien en achetant un actif qui
nous vaut intrinsèquement rien grâce à
des gogos qui n'y comprennent rien sauf
la promesse effectivement de faire
fortune alors comment est-ce qu'on
régule les humeurs humaine je pense que
là on est dans un domaine qui touche à
la morale et on ça nous éloigne
effectivement un petit peu de la finance
mais la plupart décrite aux actifs leur
os sont complètement taux orchestrées
elon musk ne s'est pas contenté
d'ailleurs d'annoncer et les amis ça y
est j'ai des bitcoins et faisant doubler
pratiquement la somme que la société
avait investi il a également parlé du
dodge coyne your dog
icogne ce qui est presque une crypto
farce mais tous les tous les fans le
suivent aveuglément
je vous parlais des gogos qui n'y
comprennent rien
la seule chose c'est que même s'il n'y
comprennent rien si on peut doubler la
mise dans la semaine et bien et le nord
ce qui est juste un e génie et c'est
vrai que helmes ne gagnera pas d'argent
avec ces voitures avant très longtemps
ils en gagnent grâce aux crédits carbone
ce qui est partie parfaitement légal ça
qu'il revend des droits
à polluer à ses concurrents ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que ses concurrents
subventionne tesla et il a également
utilisé toutes les ficelles fitial ce
qui est là aussi légal et les économies
d'impôts qu'il réalise puisque tu es
cela n'est pas imposé mais au contraire
et créditeurs vis-à-vis du fisc chaque
octet cela ne paye pas d'impôts mais est
payé par le contribuable américain
entre 6 et 7% et par un tour de passe
passe comptable il transforme la
subvention fiscale en bénéfices
complètement fictif la grâce aux bitcoin
là il va vraiment réaliser des bénéfices
mais est ce que c'est la vocation d'une
entreprise que de spéculer sur des beats
coy en joueurs de son pouvoir
d'influencé sur des gogos qui ne sont
motivées que par l'appât du gain est ce
qu'une société peut aller très loin
continue de se développer avec de tels
ressorts économiques et psychologiques
olivier rapidement avant de se quitter
il ne reste plus beaucoup de temps
qu'elle
quels sont les risques de ces
comportements sur l'économie réelle
on voit les risques de ces comportements
c'est que c'est qu'à un moment les
titres s'écrouler la bourse s'écroule
mais philippe disait qu'il n'y avait pas
de possibilité de réguler s'il y en a
une on met le musk en tôle et croyez moi
les autres vont réfléchir après aaa le
haut risque de deux de faire ce genre de
manipulation c'est réellement ça qu'il
faut faire c'est à dire tu y étant qui
aura pas un jour une presse une vraie
sanction envers les gens qui manipulent
les cours comme ça et bien évidemment
ils vont continuer si vous leur coller
d'aider des amants même de 27 millions
de dollars pour un type qui est plus
pluri milliardaire tout en n'ayant rien
fait c'est évidemment pas assez donc un
jour vous les mettez en tôle et croyez
moi ça va ça va régler le problème très
rapidement merci beaucoup olivier merci
philippe béchade avoir été parmi nous
dans cette émission
je rappelle que vous êtes ancien trader
et rédacteur en chef de la bourse au
quotidien merci beaucoup olivier on
continue fille avec les questions cash
question de jean baptiste olivier quels
stigmates cette mauvaise gestion de la
crise va-t-elle laisser sur l'union
européenne donne tel un boulevard à
d'autres pays
bah écoutez depuis depuis le début de la
crise mais je dirais il n'y a pas eu que
la crise qu vide
on a vu on a vu depuis la crise de 2008
que l'europe avait du mal à exister et
que on a eu une suite une suite de
bêtises qui ont été faites et on voit
que ça marche pas donc aujourd'hui
dites moi quel est l'apport positif de
l'europe pour des pays comme l'italie
pour des pays comme l'espagne le
portugal la grèce la france
moi je vois pas donc peut-être que
d'autres la voient moi j'ai dû beaucoup
de mal à la voir
donc là on a prouvé une impuissance
totale depuis la crise du coronavirus où
on a vu des pays qui se piquait sur le
tarmac des aéroports les masques une
europe incapable de fournir en temps et
en temps utile des vaccins des masques
avant et enfin une totale une totale
aberration et pendant ce temps là on a
fait des chèques à tour de bras pour
entretenir des des gens dans ce danser
dans cette communauté européenne
on vous dit on va se fâcher on va
montrer les muscles contre monsieur
erdogan en turquie
mais d'un autre côté on lui déverse des
milliards
tous les ans pour ce après rentrer dans
l'europe
donc tout ça c'est une blague si on a vu
que c'était c'était n'importe quoi que
ça nous ça nous apporte est absolument
rien et je pense que la crise du coc
vide a été encore plus révélatrice d'une
incapacité de l'europe à gérer quoi que
ce soit merci olivier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de votre fidélité
pour voir ou revoir nos précédents
numéros
rendez vous sur notre site internet à
l'adresse rt france point tv et puis
n'oubliez pas aussi de poser toutes vos
questions à olivier sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag rt cash on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine et olivier
ans quitte avec votre dernier mot et
bien encore une fois bon anniversaire
est elle